a bell of awakening tolls and the
unconditionally of Ash welcome everyone
to Dark Souls 3 in this episode we're
going to be taking out the ashen judge
exploring the new Firelink shrine and
once again fighting through the high
wall of lothric except this time a new
buffs awaits we start to explore killing
all the scattered hollows that litter
the graveyard and the first item we pick
up is the ashen Estus flask on a corpse
of an elite Knight which is surely a nod
to oscar right he was leaning on
something that looked suspiciously like
a lord vessel there are actually three
Lord vessel like Bowls in this episode
alone so see if you can spot them bit of
a challenge for you and then there's
this message pull back and as soon as
you read this you're like oh [ __ ] I
gotta go back this isn't safe what if
there's an asylum demon down here or no
go guarding treasure or a giant crystal
lizard that drops an incredibly valuable
scale these lizards are back with a
vengeance I feel like finally they've
evolved to a more dangerous state and
are getting revenge for all their
children that you've been killing in the
past few games that's my head Canon for
it at least in terms of real story their
scale description says that in rare
cases crystal lizards devour Souls
growing to monstrous proportions and you
might be noticing that shortbow it's a
little bit better than it used to be
right and it is I really like this
playstyle where you fall back for a few
fast shots and then when they close the
gap you slash at them with melee it's
proactive and varied and fun and I
really like the way weapon arts are
shaping up so far we use this same
technique really soon against the boss
of the tutorial
but first let's admire a few things
first up this arrow dodge hit detection
czar pretty on point and second these
views
this build is running on ps4 and it's
definitely one upped blood-borne
graphically in my opinion and see that
over there that's the new Firelink
shrine and guarding it is you decks
gun-deer the ashen judge within his
chest is the coiled sword this sword is
only bequeathed to chose an ash as
judged by the you Dex who awaits the
arrival of ash as a scabbard and to
quote another item description his back
has become a growing seed bed for
darkness it doesn't feel right to
commentate this first fight so enjoy
did you see what happened at the end
there that little moment where I checked
for arrows threw me off so much it
stopped me dodging and I think it
stopped me killing him too good fight
though right
I was pretty on point with my Perry's
but that dagger made the fight really
tough didn't do so well with my Perry's
in the second fight I got to admire this
guy's move set and animations though in
my final fight I remembered that this
black tar monster is pretty susceptible
to file
before we get into filing shrine get a
load of dingy down over here
this guy is an absolute bastard you
thought the last boss was tough try
fighting this naked dude with a katana
whether it be the stun locking my
inability to parry him three times his
godlike ability to parry me but after
about eight deaths
I found his well our weakness gravity
now a lot of people are going to
stubbornly kill this guy like I did but
a katana class weapon this early on is a
pretty sweet reward and compared to
blood-borne I can confirm that this game
is great at giving you a lot of weapons
in the early game I had access to over
thirty in the first three hours which is
awesome and finally let's get into
filing shrine and as we enter pay
special attention to the music I loved
how it intertwined with the dialogue of
the characters and the tone it lends to
this place
ah another one roused from the sleep of
death well you're not alone
we unkilled our worthless can't even die
right
gives me conniptions and they have us
seek the Lords of single or return them
to their moulding Thrones but we are
talking true legends with the metal to
note the fire we don't fit to lick their
boots don't you think the Lords of
cinder awoke but turned their backs on
their thrones and their duty it's our
job to bring them back
welcome to the bonfire and kindled one
I'm a fire keeper
I tend to the flame
I tend to be
terms
to this end I'm at thy side
while Russian one
I got so nostalgic when I saw Andre at
the end of this tunnel I ran straight
past one of the hags from Dark Souls 2
and went to talk to our old blacksmith
from Dark Souls 1 well a new camera she
died in laundry I serve at this shrine
as a humble Smith forging weapons
you're in search of the Lords of cinder
I trust
toilsome journey I wager you require
good arms
let me Smith your weapons I am a Smith
such as my purpose but hey be careful I
don't want to see my work squandered the
blacksmith fulfills really familiar
tasks plus the ability to choose how
many of each Estus flask you'd like
pleasure to make thine acquaintance
ashen one I am but a humble handmaid of
the shrine weapons Armour trinkets and
spells
I've lots of little things to ease the
burden of a weary traveler
and yes I'm undead too but not so
charitable is to give my goods away the
torch is the most appropriate thing to
buy here for now but I am definitely
eyeing that key that requires 20k souls
the handmaiden also extends her wares
when you bring her ash ashes are the
remains of heroes you find on your
journey and the new items she gets
pertain to the type of ash that you
bring is it not our sorry fate to suck
on death so the thrones belong to the
Lords of cinder who abandoned them and
very fittingly they all seem to resemble
gravestones for to sit upon them means
sacrificing yourself to link the fire
you're the giant of the profaned capital
the largest throne of course Farren's
undead legion the abyss watchers you can
see their swords lizard upon their
throne holy King lothric last hope of
his line Aldrich st. of the deep you can
see the almost plastic like covering
around it protecting it from his body
and finally loot left the exiled who
apparently still remains on his throne
all that on Kindle and a seeker of lords
I am Ludlow's of corner look not in
bewilderment as I say I linked the fire
long ago becoming the Lord of cinder
if substantiation did I want set thine
eyes upon my childhood course this sad
could ever no need to be coy have a
closer look
no star of our paths five Thrones we'll
take five Lords as kindling for the
linking of the fire
the fast-fading flame must be licked to
preserve this world a reenactment of the
first linking of the fire so it is I
became a lord of cinder
I may be but small but I will die a
colossus leveling up remains much the
same but there's the addition of the
luck stat which makes a return from
demon souls luck increases item drop
rates as well as a few other minor
things probably and while we level up
the fire keeper is chanting something
let these souls withdrawn from their
vessels manifestations of disparity
elucidated by fire burrow deep within me
retreating to a darkness beyond the
reach of flame let them assume a new
master inhabiting ash casting themselves
upon new forms a ssin one produce the
coiled sword at the bonfire the mark of
ash will guide thee to the land of the
lords to lothric where the homes of the
lords converge so that was file link our
new home for Dark Souls 3 and unlike in
previous Dark Souls games it doesn't
seem to be connected to the rest of the
world so the closest comparison to this
hub will be Demon Souls since that game
had a disconnected hub that you send
NPCs back - but to me the strongest part
of Dark Souls was its intertwined
interconnected world and areas including
the hub so if this is a step away from
that then I'm honestly a little bit
disappointed because the ability to walk
to every checkpoint from a disconnected
hub is definitely going to affect
exploration and world design regardless
though time will tell if this is a
problem or not and once again we fight
our way through the high wall of lothric
where the homes of the Lords of cinder
converge
and most of you have seen this area but
there are some new things for example
all the enemies now drop items and since
I chose the gold coins as my gift I
ended up being able to increase my luck
and I got really really lucky with my
drops I'm going to come right out and
say it
out of all the footage that comes out of
this event on March 1st I reckon we end
up with the most fashionable character
consider that a challenge to the other
uploaders I guess and of course since
all these items dropped for me I can
teach us a lot about the lothric Knights
these nights of lothric with their
Drake's once crushed anything that
threatened their Shores of course there
was a long long time ago the knight has
served as one of the three pillars since
ancient times and shares place alongside
the wyverns as a symbol of law 3 on the
flip side though the lothric Knights are
also said to have contended with the
Dragons and their shields have lightning
resistance which is befitting of the
dragon slayers arms their crossbows are
also blessed with the power of lightning
in anticipation of the use of lightning
bolts which we know are effective
against dragons so they fight with and
against dragons and the lightning urn
explains this to us it tells us that the
Knights of lothric have since tamed
dragons but were once hunters of dragons
and finally they worshiped the Sun so
many connections here between lothric
the land of the lords lightning Sun Gwyn
it's all here as we enter lothric castle
we expect the dancer of the frigid
Valley but now in her place is Emma who
sits beneath a restricted ladder leading
deeper into lothric castle a castle
rumored to devour men
ah the weight has been long and kindled
one I am Emma High Priestess of lothric
castle allow me to speak frankly you
will not find the Lords of cinder here
they have left gone to their journey
homes converging at the base of this
castle head to the bottom of the high
wall for Jon through the great gate and
raised this banner to proceed this
farewell gift is for you it is the
insignia of an Old Covenant if you fear
trespassers dark spirit stone by the
embers then etch this upon your heart
and the old Concord will beckon noble
blue sentinels to hunt these foul
spirits covenants are now changeable on
the fly which is great there's an
inventory slot that holds your
allegiance uncontained one head to the
high wall space go through the great
gate and raise this banner to proceed
but beware the dog keeps a close eye on
things the vial watchdog of the boreal
valley
in Episode two we face off against the
vile watchdog and we find an old friend
in a towel I can't wait to show you guys
that it's going to be amazing I don't
usually ask for this but if you could
leave a like that would be so fantastic
I really want this series to do well and
this series is going to get better come
March 24th when the Japanese version
comes out because I won't have time
restrictions on the amount of content I
can upload so we'll be able to go more
in depth on so many of the interesting
things that I've had to cut out of this
series in the name of time restrictions
you guys have no idea how hard it is to
cut down like six hours of footage to a
mere 45 minutes or so that's been really
tough and also having the full game on
March 24th means I'll be able to record
at my own pace not just in one big
sitting so the production value will go
up and I just want to say thank you for
supporting this series thank you for
watching thanks for being patrons if you
are and I'll see you in the next one